the bad news for joe biden is that most
americans blame him for the collapse of
afghanistan the worst news for joe biden
is that most americans don't think he
can even finish his presidential term
some people say this is the end of the
road for biden some say it's the end of
the road for america and still other
people myself included
say it's the end of the world as we know
it i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from mj who says
breaking news
biden demands whoever the president is
to take full responsibility for this
mess
i could not possibly agree more with
joe's statement we have got to track
down whoever is running the country i
don't know i don't know who it is joe
don't know who it is
but whoever it is is not doing a great
job if you want something done right you
got to do it yourself which is why i
would recommend rock auto when you want
a part for your car or truck you can
either do it yourself rockauto.com
super easy reliably low prices you can
always you get you know you don't have
to wait on tuesday afternoon is going to
be the special deal or wednesday or it's
a different price for pros and do
yourself so you can either do that
or
you can go to the auto parts store brick
and mortar you you pull up you get out
of your car if your car is still driving
you walk in you wait in line you're
waiting
then you get up there the guy says hey
what's what year what make what color
what model what this with that with that
and so in like 10 minutes goes by okay
let me go see if i got the part it goes
in the back they probably don't have any
parts in there frankly there's too many
parts to stock so i think it goes on
he orders the party charges you twice as
much he comes out says yeah okay that'll
be you know whatever however much money
it's overpriced and you're gonna have to
wait a few weeks and um okay bye then
you go walk out back out get your car
drive home why would you do that you've
just wasted so much time and money go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car truck and then
write nulls in there how did you hear
about asbox so they know that we sent
you poll just came out from the daily
wires this is an exclusive poll we
commissioned with surveymonkey
we have discovered here at dw
and by the way i know some people think
oh you know it's a fox news poll that's
right wing or it's a cbs poll that's
left-wing or i mean these polls follow
pretty rigorous methodology and we're
making sure that we if anything are
being a little generous to the democrat
side of the aisle so that we're not
being accused of bias and our poll has
just discovered that americans believe
the taliban takeover of afghanistan
is biden's fault not trump's fault a lot
of people are trying to blame trump now
they're saying he made the deal with the
taliban he set biden up or whatever you
know they're just trying to avoid
responsibility joe biden has at least
ostensibly been president for eight
months now but the american people
aren't buying it 36
of americans believe that biden is
responsible for the current crisis in
afghanistan that's compared to 21 of
americans who fault donald trump and
then this is important too 29 of
americans say it's neither trump nor
biden's fault
i i put a somewhat longer piece up
yesterday at the daily wire with my take
on afghanistan which is a little bit
different than the take of my colleagues
here at the daily wire and i think it's
a little bit different than you're
hearing really anywhere else in the
conservative movement but it gets to
that that question is it is it trump's
fault
no is it biden's fault a little bit but
there's a broader problem in afghanistan
independence by the way and this is
really bad news for biden come 2022 and
2024 if he's even still president
independents are twice as likely to
blame biden
than to blame trump for the debacle so
that's really bad news because if the
assuming the voter integrity laws are
somewhat reins reinstituted at least
that means that democrats are really
going to have to win over the middle and
the independence and and right now
especially on this issue they are
breaking heavily for for the republicans
now the question of 2024
raises the specter of who's going to be
the democrat nominee we don't know
nobody believes that joe biden is fully
lucid okay i'm i'm not taking cheap
partisan shots here i'm not trying to be
an armchair psychologist
for those of you out there i know there
are some of you who support joe biden do
you really believe that this guy is
totally with it he's totally lucid all
day long
i don't think so
i don't think anyone believes that
especially after the way he handled the
afghanistan communications not even the
lead up to pulling out but the
communications afterward
afghanistan collapses and then joe biden
disappears he's at camp david no one
hears from him no one talks to him he
finally gives an address to the nation
and it's at
three o'clock in the afternoon
these these sorts of addresses to the
nation are usually in prime time they're
usually from the oval office but they're
certainly in prime time
you think of addresses from obama but
from trump from bush i mean basically
every a major presidential address on a
topic such as this for my lifetime and
further back has been during prime time
seven eight o'clock at night
and yet
the biden
press conference
three o'clock in the afternoon what's
that about is he maybe not all with it
later on in the day is it is that why
they had to wait a few days
it's not just me who's raising these
questions rasmussen asked a thousand
likely voters how likely is it that joe
biden will leave office and be replaced
by kamala harris before 2024
it's not even that a plurality said that
it's very likely
or somewhat likely
it's it's a majority 51
of likely voters
said that it is very or somewhat likely
that biden will leave office before 2024
that's compared to just
uh 37 who say that it is not very or not
at all likely
not a good place this this is why you're
going to see democrats continue to
double down on covet it's the only issue
that biden has any positive numbers on
so he's going to lean into that he's
going to try to ignore immigration he's
definitely going to try to ignore
afghanistan and then they're going to
try to cheat which is what they always
do and i know we're not allowed to raise
the prospect of voter fraud because our
big tech overlords who are
proxies and instruments by which
democrats cheat at elections like they
did the last time
they don't want us to say that there's
ever any question of fraud but look at
what's happening in california right now
okay so i
probably received a ballot in california
even though i moved out many months ago
because they're sending ballots to
everybody and i've heard from i've heard
from multiple friends in california that
they're getting
not just a ballot but multiple ballots
they're getting ballots that weren't
supposed to be sent to them
so it's a complete mess by design one
suspects
but then there was a video just came out
from a california voter on the recall
right now the the recall election of
gavin newsom has two questions should
the democratic governor be recalled yes
or no if
50 plus one voter says yes he should be
recalled then it goes to the second
question who
should replace him and you just answer
both so
take a listen to this woman's
description of what her ballot looks
like make sure that you put yes
that means that yes you want gavin
newsom to lose his job
um the next thing you're gonna check
is who you're going to vote for to
replace him
i am going to vote for larry elder
and his box is on the back of the page
um
i think that it is important that we
unite around one candidate but like i
said the most important thing is that we
get him out
um
this is the sketchy part this is the
crazy part so
when you fold up your ballot
more than likely it seems natural
you're just gonna slip this in
but you have to pay attention to these
two holes
that are in the front of the envelope
you can see
if someone from the outside of the mail
on ballot you can see if somebody has
voted yes to recall new sim
this is so
freaking clever
it's so wrong but it's so clever so on
the mail-in ballots there are two holes
just like you took a little hole puncher
and i guess this is for sorting purposes
or i don't know i've seen them on the
envelopes before
they're two little holes right on either
side of where you sign your name to say
this is my ballot
the only question that matters on this
ballot just one question says should we
recall gavin newsom and it's placed kind
of bizarrely on the ballot it's placed
in kind of the middle column a little up
toward the first top half of the page
and then you saw all the way on the
right and all the way up and down you
see who should we replace him with but
the question should we or should we not
recall gavin newsom
so if you can either darken the circle
yes or darken the circle no
and just coincidentally
the circle for yes
lines up
perfectly
with the hole on the envelope
meaning
you can see
with
great a great degree of certainty from
the outside of the envelope whether or
not this ballot
is to recall gavin newsom
and you know
if that circle happens to be a little
dark i wonder you know what happens to
that ballot
does that ballot does something happen
does it disappear does it is it is there
an error with it is it
or is maybe the signature not quite
right
i don't know
of all this a very long ballot of all
the places that the only question that
matters could possibly be on that sheet
of paper front
or back
it just so happens to line up perfectly
with the hole in the envelope
what are the odds
what are
the odds such
it's so typical it's it's clever but
it's typical you see things like this a
lot before and this is why we neither
trust nor like our government
this is why we want to recall the people
who are running our government
like gavin newsom which brings me to
some of the news from yesterday
you may have heard
there was a threat
at capitol hill
there was a bomb threat on capitol hill
and there was a video a live stream from
the person who made the threat take a
listen
they sitting in cars all over this place
around here because you thought the
south wasn't coming
well joe biden the south come
the roads are
blocked i'm waiting on your phone call
it's your call
you got an option
you can shoot me and kill me right here
and blow up two and a half city blocks
and let all the patrons out in the
country know
because i ain't here to blow nobody up
ain't here to hurt nobody
if i was i wouldn't have told them to
tell people to leave
i would have gunned this [ __ ]
wrote it right up in your front door
[Music]
but i'm here for a reason joe biden
[Music]
i'm here for a reason
i'm here for the american people
thankfully this guy was taken into
custody was disarmed nobody got hurt it
wasn't
there was no horrible consequence of
this most interesting though is not what
he did or what the cops did it's that a
lot of people don't believe that any of
this is real
so the big trending news
all of yesterday is the capital bomb
threat
even as afghanistan is in the news major
probably the worst debacle
so far of the biden administration i
guess
compared to the immigration problem it's
their neck and neck one is the major
domestic debacle one is a major foreign
debacle
but
a really bad week for joe biden and then
this is in the news that this
may be right winger i mean he doesn't
like joe biden he's from the south
there's a chance he's a right winger
that he's there trying to blow up the
capital
so
the cops disarm him
they take him into custody we haven't
heard very much since
to me what's much more interesting
is if you look in the comments section
on people on the video on articles about
the video
it's a lot of people saying yeah this
looks staged this looks fake
this isn't real
this is an op
this is just they're trying to pull
another one over on us
now
i'm not i'm not saying that's the case i
think he's just a guy who was a kook and
now he's been taken into custody
but i understand why people
don't think this is real
they don't think it's real for the
political reason that our leaders lie to
us and they cheat and they rig things
and they try to pull a fast one and our
administrative state the bureaucracy the
deep state the surveillance state has
gotten completely out of control and we
know that not only do they perform
clandestine activities on americans but
they lie about it too i mean we know
this from the fact that the the
surveillance state spied on donald trump
at the behest of barack obama during the
2016 election we know that they
continually tried to subvert his
presidency we know that they spy on
americans they were spying on tucker
carlson for goodness sakes so we know
these sorts of things happen
uh
so that would be one that'd be the
political reason we just don't trust
these guys
but there's the technological reason too
it all seems
like a movie
i mean it literally is a movie the only
reason anyone knows about this is
because this guy is live streaming it
from his truck and we're all inside his
truck with him
and we know that technology can be very
deceiving with the advent of deep fakes
with the advent of
just streaming technology generally
these these sorts of things can be
produced and cultivated and curated
for our consumption for a particular
end of communications we don't
this is much deeper than just we don't
like our government and we don't trust
them i mean that's a big problem too
but it's a it's a technological
revolution that's taken place that is
that is challenging our belief in
reality itself
we just don't i i can no longer believe
my lying eyes
in a world with the ability to
manipulate media and push it out to
millions and millions and millions of
people as we have
we can no longer just believe the things
that we see even with our it used to be
don't believe everything you see in in
newspapers now it's don't believe
everything you see
on video or here or perhaps even with
your own eyes
which brings us to another
aspect of this from the so-called
private sector which is from apple you
you may or may not have heard about this
story
but
very shortly
apple is going to start scanning the
images on your phone and on your ipad
and on other apple products
to see if you have any illegal content
they're just just the the images that
you keep on your phone just whatever you
know your kid or your baby or maybe some
things that are less savory than that i
guess that's actually what apple's going
after
they're just gonna scan it
and they're gonna upload it to servers
and they're going to scan it through
machine learning
and then if you have images that are
deemed illegal then
individuals are going to review them and
then if the individuals confirm that
they're illegal they're going to send
them to the authorities and you might
get a knock on your door from the men in
black
without even knowing that anyone was
looking into you
now what's the what's the good part of
this the good part of this is
it's aimed to go after child pornography
right that's that's at least the the
reason that apple is giving
and we all agree if you're if some guy
is downloading lots of child pornography
or selling it or what trading it or
whatever then he's a sick puppy and he
ought to go to prison or to face
consequences for that
but
it is stopping those guys worth this
because something tells me that when we
give
big tech and by the way apple is the
best of all of the big tech companies in
terms of privacy famously apple is
infinitely better than
google certainly the google google
facebook all the rest of them apple has
refused to crack open the phones of of
terrorists to federal authorities that's
how seriously they take privacy so now
they're going to go in
and
scan your images
okay
if it were just if if there was some way
to guarantee it were just restricted to
child pornography i bet
maybe not everyone would go along with
it maybe some people like a ton of
privacy rights groups or would even say
even that is too far even that is is a
law enforcement measure that is that is
too invasive and we can't go along with
it but i think a lot of americans would
say okay that's fine you know if you're
just going after
pedophiles and child abusers okay that's
fine but there's no limiting principle
we know this we we know that big tech
companies do not
stop at illegal content
they banned the sitting president of the
united states
while while he was sit on january 7th
the duly elected sitting president was
de-platformed for saying things that
contradicted the political narrative
you and i were not allowed to send
damning information about the biden
family in the run-up to the
2020 election we weren't even allowed to
privately message it on social media
platforms they shut that down
when we post on instagram or twitter or
whatever some infographic about how
maybe the official narrative about the
coronavirus in terms of lethality in
terms of mitigation measures maybe it's
not totally right maybe maybe actually
the experts have gotten something wrong
you'll see a big disclaimer covering up
the image
so do we really think that giving apple
the ability to scan our phones for the
putatively ostensibly good reason of
stopping child abuse do we do we think
it's going to end there i don't believe
that for a second i don't believe that
for a second
i have no problem taking away the
privacy of child abusers and throwing
them in prison but i think that's an
excuse i don't think that's actually
what this is going to be used for
speaking of creepy sex stuff by the way
there is some good news on the creepy
sex stuff front only fans only fans
which is a i guess it's a social media
network for
porn
i mean you know i covered this when it
first got into
sort of cropped up uh in the popular
culture because it was to me it was so
shocking not that girls are posting you
know naked images it's the world's
oldest profession first of all
and
second of all that's what the internet
is right
it's like 150 pornography and then like
two percent business
but
what was so creepy about it was it's not
the reason only fans succeeded is not
because men wanted to see naked women on
the internet you can already do that for
free right you can already you can find
any naked lady you want or any type of
naked lady or would you just type it
into google
what was creepy about only fans is
what was so perverse about it was that
the men did not just want uh to see a
naked lady they wanted a relationship i
think that's my read only fans
they wanted to subscribe they wanted to
pay money to feel as though they have a
relationship with some they'll get
special you know perks and it's
exclusive and not everyone gets to see
the lady and
that to me is very sad because it's it's
it's a channeling it's a recognition
that guys who are looking at a ton of
porn want something more than that they
want something more substantial and
relational but
instead of just going out and getting a
girlfriend or a wife or something
that's a little healthier they'll just
channel that into a different kind of
porn so
a lot of people have been going after
this also because it suckers in girls
who want to make a quick buck and it has
to make decisions that will affect the
rest of their lives and that they
certainly will come to regret
so only fans
is banning sexual content
you never you never hear of something
getting better in the culture
but only fans
and they're doing this because they
recognize
that
their regulation is coming that people
are turning against this sort of thing
the licentious you know do whatever you
want like whatever you want
you know just don't scare the horses in
the street that attitude is going away
and the attitude of the internet is the
complete wild west that's going away too
and so only fans is trying to secure
a more stable platform i mean this is
what they said in order to ensure the
long-term sustainability of our platform
and to continue to host an inclusive
community of creators and fans
we must evolve our content guidelines i
there's so rarely good news in the
culture on this front but good stuff
good stuff for the culture good stuff
for the guys who subscribe good stuff
for the girls who are making a buck on
it right now and will come to regret it
speaking of gainful employment
there was a story out of capitol hill
this was probably a couple weeks ago now
and we didn't have time to get to it on
the show but i don't want to let this go
because it shows you what's wrong with
the republican party so you know
senate republicans helped green soar a
green light rather this infrastructure
bill it mostly was not actually an
infrastructure bill it was mostly just a
bunch of
random democrat spending but there was a
tiny little bit of infrastructure in it
and so they called it the infrastructure
bill
it wasn't just democrats here because
democrats could have held it up 19
republicans
went along with it
i'm going to say their names dan
sullivan shelley murcapido mike crappo
is that his name
roy blunt richard burr deb fischer
lindsey graham rob portman tom tillis
lisa murkowski john risch chuck grassley
bill cassidy kevin kramer
roger wicker mitch mcconnell joe hoeven
susan collins and mitt romney so
even if you don't recognize every name
on that list i don't recognize every
name on the list but these are the
squishes right these are generally the
squishier
republicans
and they've gone along with this
infrastructure bill okay well they want
to pass something that's fine a
provision of this bill
will provide giant carveouts for
industries to to bypass the buy american
rules that were particularly pushed by
the trump administration this idea that
okay if the government wants to spend a
jillion dollars they've got to spend it
here they've got to employ american
workers they've got to employ american
factories and producers yes it's going
to cost a little bit more money first of
all they're spending trillions of
dollars already so give me a break but
you know you're now now you're worried
about cutting costs when you have to
employ americans now now you're worried
now you want to pinch pennies
but this is a
a sort of america first provision that
we'd finally brought back in
and this is typical of countries that
are serious about
about growing their
their stature their manufacturing
their position in the world taking care
of their workers
this is this is something you saw you
see as far back as louis xiv in
versailles this idea that you've you've
got to
buy french wear french support the
french people that there's that there is
a loyalty
beyond the almighty dollar that there is
a loyalty beyond getting the best deal
and that is to america that there's
something about buying a mirror i
remember this when i was a kid people
would buy american cars because they
said we want to put food on americans
tables we want to support our country
ronald reagan talked about this stuff
now you just don't see it anymore it
used to be if you were on a political
campaign democrat or republican
and you wanted to buy bumper stickers or
lawn signs you had to buy
made in america union made both parties
they did this because they were
appealing to the american worker and a
sense of patriotism and loyalty to the
country now i'm not sure that either
party does that
or at least not consistently
but we don't care any that no one seems
to have all that much loyalty
to
america the nation or americans more
broadly speaking of american interests
overseas the ap has revealed yesterday
up to 15 000 americans remain in
afghanistan after the country's collapse
no plan whatsoever to take them out
other countries are using special forces
to get their people out joe biden says
yeah we can't do it we don't know we're
trying i don't know well hopefully the
taliban will let the americans out
absolutely pathetic speaking of contempt
for americans there's an article in the
washington post we can't miss
this i think this sums it all up
quote an alabama doctor watched patients
reject the coronavirus vaccine now he's
refusing to treat them
that's it
jason valentine is a doctor in alabama
he says look
these p i'm telling them they can get
the vaccine
but you know if they don't want to get
the vaccine then i'm not going to treat
them i'm not going to provide them
medicine they're not doing everything i
told them to do to prevent the infection
so no i'm not going to treat them
anymore sorry
he says if they asked i told them
kovid's a miserable way to die and i
can't watch them die like that sorry
wow yeah that'll show them right a lot
of left-wingers cheering this on
i even hate to say
what if it were on the other foot what
if hypothetically because that
conservatism is going to die with the
what-ifs and the imagine if this were on
the other foot but but still
imagine if it were aids
just imagine if it were aids yeah a
doctor says you should not engage in
homosexual behavior
because that dramatically dramatically
increases your chances of contracting
aids so you know if you do if you're a
gay guy then i'm just not going to treat
you if you have aids i'm not going to
treat you i told you not to do it and so
look aids is a miserable way to die and
so i'm just not going to treat you sorry
just don't do it
can you imagine can you imagine oh
forget even aids for a second
a doctor's not going to treat fat guys
no fat look if actually if you're fat
that dramatically increases your risk of
dying from coronavirus
and a myriad of other health conditions
sorry buddy now you've been eating too
many burgers you're no longer my patient
no of course not
the reason that they can do it with the
the non-vax issue
is because it tends to be conservatives
who are a little more skeptical
conservatives and and black americans
who are generally not conservative but
we the democrats sort of forget that
they're
resistant to the vaccine but
conservatives say uh you know i'm not
that worried about the virus and uh you
know i don't really trust dr fauci or
anybody so yeah maybe i'm not gonna get
the vaccine and because we're now
permitted to
other we're now permitted to scapegoat
we're now permitted to publicly deride
and ostracize
conservatives
they can now even be denied medical care
and the washington post will cheer them
on
contempt for americans
right now in the largest county in
virginia
that county this is virginia the one of
the true
home places of america george washington
state
for america's 250th birthday which it is
this year
this county will not celebrate
america's birthday they will
commemorate it
the reason is fairfax county's
semi-quinceant
semi-quincentennial working group has
that word say that five times fast said
that uh
events and i'm sorry in 2026 not this
year in 2026 should be a commemoration
of
of america's birthday and not just 1776
but also 1607 jamestown and 1619 the tr
the new true founding of the country now
why the government commissioned a survey
that said that 65
of respondents thought it should be
called a celebration so the vast
majority think it should be called a
celebration but the researcher ignored
the results of this survey
because
it the the people who wanted it to be a
celebration skewed traditional
rather than neoteric those are fancy
words to say it was the conservatives
who wanted the celebration and the libs
wanted it to be called a commemoration
and so because a minority a distinct
minority of liberals don't want to
celebrate america we're not going to
celebrate america anymore that's the way
the country works
that's the way it's not just the end for
joe biden if we can't get it together if
we can't if we don't have any faith in
our institutions if we don't like our
country if we think that our country is
basically a tragedy and even if the
majority of americans don't agree with
that if the people in power
think that our country is a tragedy
barely if it must be to be commemorated
certainly never celebrated
then it's not just the end of the line
for the biden administration
it's the end of the line period for the
civilization
you know if you want to stay well read
and informed
the daily wire readers pass is for you
for just four bucks a month the daily
wire readers pass unlocks exclusive
editorial content that unpacks trending
political and cultural topics
penned by everyone from candace owens to
dan crenshaw
to most importantly me when you sign up
with readers pass you get access to the
morning wire newsletter
a monday through saturday email covering
the top stories you need to know
available only to daily wire members so
act fast because right now we're
offering a one month free trial
get that reader's pass today also if
you're a fan of the matt wall show then
you've probably heard of his sweet baby
gang
i i just heard of this the other day
what it what a title what a beautiful
title the sweet baby gang is in need of
a sweet baby anthem
the daily wire is opening up for
submissions all submissions should be in
the form of youtube video links will be
judged american idol style by matt and
all of us daily wire hosts but you the
viewer will be voting on which song wins
so go to dailywire.com
sbg submissions end on august 25th
voting will take place on labor day so
tune in to the matt walsh youtube
channel to watch the judging of
submissions the winner will be on
september 8th on the matt wall show go
to dailywire.com sbg anything else to
plug guys we good all right we'll be
right back with the mailbag
first question from camille
michael do you believe in ghosts in my
catholic high school i had one teacher
tell us that ghosts are in fact real but
if they are trying to interact with us
they're most likely bad because good
souls would not be in limbo in our
physical world what are your thoughts on
this sincerely who you gonna call
yes ghosts are real
they are they're real it's undeniable
that ghosts are real there is more
twixt heaven and earth than is dreamt of
in our philosophy horatio
ghosts appear in the bible sometimes you
will hear christians say ghosts if you
think you see a ghost you can say with
100 certainty it's a demon it's not
really a ghost
ghosts are in the bible
ghosts are in the first book of samuel
ghosts are in i believe second maccabees
ghosts
are in the in the new testament
you see moses and elijah
in the transfiguration but they're not
they're they have not yet been
resurrected so they're go what is it a
ghost it comes from the word geist it
means spirit so yeah our spirit's real
yes spirits are real and do we have
evidence of them appearing
to humans uh yeah we do actually we i
know that the material the scientific
materialists are going to laugh at me
the secularists are going to laugh at me
when i say that but yeah we have a lot
of evidence one we see it in the bible
so if you're a christian or a jew then
certainly you would have to admit that
ghosts are real but even if you're a
hardened
stone-cold
agnostic or atheist
we have
reports of people seeing ghosts seeing
spirits of strange phenomena
everywhere for all of history
in every single culture in every single
place on earth up to and including the
present day
we have these unexplained phenomena we
have anecdotal tales of people seeing
spirits
things that cannot be explained so it
just seems to me as a cultural matter i
know that you probably can't see the
ghost under a microscope but it just
seems to me first of all there is more
between heaven and earth and is dreamt
of in our philosophy
if you have even the sl slightest
modicum of humility you have to admit
that
and
it seems as a cultural matter we can
infer that yes there is something going
on here we know that we have spirits
again if you're
unless you're the most hardened
materialist of all you have to admit
that we have something like a spirit
i mean transgenderism the whole
transgender ideology is based on the
idea not only that we have spirits but
that our spirits are entirely our true
selves and our body is not our true self
right so even even people who are maybe
atheistic or think that they're
atheistic or agnostic in modernity
even they
believe that there is such a thing as a
spirit
and uh yeah and and that the spirit and
the body are
distinct
and that spirits are are around
sometimes you should not uh seek out
mediums or things like that to
communicate with ghosts that's a bad
idea
you should not engage in necromancy the
bible also says don't do that that's
that's not good stuff
and they and also demons are real too i
know i mean maybe we'll wait for another
question to go into how obviously angels
and demons are real but uh yeah you i
mean sometimes demons can mess with
people so don't you know like don't seek
them out but are ghosts real 100
from noah dear michael this question is
about relationships again here we go i'm
pursuing a relationship and things seem
promising with the one woman i mentioned
earlier however i can't help but feel
guilty that i'm a porn addict while in
pursuit of her i'm just going to pause
it here
it's good of you to write in this
question because it's an embarrassing
topic to talk about
how many questions do i get i get this
is like half my mailbag is guys writing
in that they're dealing with porn and
then i
we we'll discuss on the show how maybe
we should regulate pornography and then
we're told by the libertarian types that
this would be you know the greatest
greatest tragedy in american history
just listen to the number of young men
even who just right into this one show
clearly a problem ties in also with the
only fans talk today okay question goes
on this guilt is basically like when one
receives the eucharist in an unworthy
state
there are times where i feel that i need
to take the time to make myself worthy
of her hand but i fear that i might lose
this chance during that time what should
i do
yeah if you wait until your perfect
buddy you're never going to get married
and definitely this chickie's going to
move on and because it's going to take
you a while okay but i don't mean to
make light of your problem this is a
serious problem and you really
you really ought to stop it and you need
to stop it the thing
that you need to remember
is that
virtue and vice are habits
contrary to what we are told in modern
theories of the mind that that
liken the mind to a steam engine or to a
computer or something like that
you are not your
vices are not alleviated by blowing off
a little steam or by just changing a few
lines of code or something
your mind is more like a muscle
right you you
virtue becomes easier the more you do it
just like lifting weights becomes easier
the more you do it so i so i'm told i
you know i don't have a ton of direct
experience with this or vice becomes
easier the more that you do it and
harder to break the more that you do it
actually
so what i would recommend you do it
sounds like you're catholic because
you're talking about receiving the
eucharist outside the state of grace
what i would recommend you do is go to
confession regularly obviously i think
there's great spiritual benefit to this
but even for people out there who are
not catholic or they don't believe that
much
there is also just a psychological
effect there is a physical effect to
getting on your knees to confessing this
sin to a guy that is
that's very awkward that's very
embarrassing
it's very it's it ha it forces you to
confront the reality of the sin when you
say it out loud to another guy
and then
the
psychological effect of that not just
with porn but with any other sin
actually is that the next time you are
tempted to commit that sin
you're going to think twice about it
because you don't want to go through the
rigmarole of having to go and confess
this sin because it's embarrassing
because it forces you to confront your
own shame
that's the first thing i would do
then i was just talking to my friend
matt frat matt fradd
has famously dealt with the pornography
addiction and he said one of one of the
ways out of this is there's sort of
software that you can put on your
devices if you if you want to be held
accountable where you can uh
you know if you try to search for a porn
website it'll send an email or a text or
something to to you know you could i
don't know you could put your girlfriend
on though probably that's too much but
you could put a buddy of yours or a
family member or something to get the
email so that that would be another way
of holding yourself accountable um
i think you should keep dating the girl
but i think that you obviously your
heart's in the right place you want to
break this addiction just like people
want to break addictions to drugs or
booze or overeating or whatever
so that's good that's the first step now
you have to set concrete tangible
measures in place to force you into that
and it will be very difficult just like
breaking any addiction will be very very
difficult and you should give yourself a
little bit of grace by the way you know
you don't want to turn one slip up you
don't want to turn one sip of whiskey
into a week-long bender and the same
holds true of drugs or porn or whatever
you know if you slip up then it's a slip
up and then you
get back right back on the wagon and you
just keep working on this because it's
just like working out it's just like
building up any other muscle or building
up any other skill for that matter the
same is true of virtue and uh i i don't
think you need to uh lay all of this at
the feet of your girlfriend i think
that's actually kind of weird i don't
think that's guy that's a weird
conversation you're sitting down saying
oh honey what a lovely dinner this is by
the way i'm a porn addict and i look you
know i do all these things by the way
you know i i'm i'm all i'm craving is a
drug right now or something like that no
i wouldn't do that i would just work on
this steadily you're not alone i wasn't
90 percent of men are dealing with this
but but you're not going to get anywhere
if you
just keep it all vague and you keep it
all in your mind and you just think
about it you think i'm going to really
try really hard in my mind
there's no you got to put it in your
body when you confess when you
have
strictures you know put on your
computers and things like that
that's the only way you're gonna do it i
remember one time when i was coming back
into the faith i went to confession and
i i confessed my sins in these really
vague terms you know father
i gave in to wrath you know and father i
gave into this real i was just kind of
listing off the seven deadly sins and
the priest sighed and he said
i need numbers i need dates i need
specifics otherwise if you don't keep
track of this stuff you're just going to
keep doing it you're not going to get
better and so you got to you got to
really take it seriously as you would
training for a marathon but best of luck
from brandon michael i had a question
regarding again you know what did you
ever notice this
that even if the show is almost entirely
political the mailbag
is almost entirely religious this is
because
even agnostics and atheists i think
recognize that at bottom all human
conflict is religious and you know we if
we say that politics is downstream of
culture culture is going to be
downstream of religion so he writes in
michael had a question regarding a bible
verse
and how we as christians are to abide by
it the verse i'm referring to is matthew
7
chapter 7 verse 1 where christ says
judge not lest ye be judged how are we
to comment on relevant cultural issues
such as transgenderism casual adultery
the glorification of abortion much more
without judging this is one that
sometimes stops me in my tracks when i'm
being critical of modern degeneracy but
maybe i'm looking at it the wrong way
your insights appreciated p.s i'm almost
done with speechless it was a great book
thank you oh thank you so much that's
very kind
judge not lest ye be judged
the measure that you
meet out in your judgment is the measure
that will come back to you
this is not
christ saying do not ever judge
in fact he tells his apostles judge with
right judgment he tells people that when
you go away if you have a problem with
your brother go to your brother and
confront him about it and if he doesn't
listen to you go get three other people
and you know hash it out among all of
you and then if he still remains
unrepentant then you know don't don't
deal with him anymore
he will be to you as a tax collector or
you know he'll be
he'll be anathema until he until he
writes his wrongs he's not saying that
he gives his apostles the keys to the
kingdom of heaven it says who sends you
forgiven forgiveness whose sins you
retain or retained
what he is saying is
one have a touch of humility
and two if you are going to judge
make sure you've got your own house in
order first make sure that before you
take the spec out of your brother's eye
you take the log out of your own eye
he's not saying that we can't
correct our brothers in love he's not
saying that we shouldn't
judge with right judgment as he tells
people to do elsewhere
he's saying you you've got to hold
yourself to this standard you've got to
get yourself in order as well or you
will not have credibility and you will
be hypocritical and your and your
judgments in love won't even do what
they're supposed to do
for marissa michael i have told my mom
and sister about the law of attraction
how many questions am i going to get
about the law of attraction this is that
new agey thing where people believe that
if they just
demand something of the of god and of
the universe that they will get that
thing
um it's it's very popular in this you
know that book the secret and kind of
other new age heresies so michael i told
my mom and sister about the law of
attraction what you said however they
keep saying that it is just positive
thinking bringing positive things i have
argued that that thought process is fine
but the law of attraction is not just
about positivity how can i explain to
them that positivity is great but the
law of attraction is not and those
positive things are not from it and if i
am wrong let me know sincerely pass the
positivity yeah you're right your
family's wrong
the power of positive thinking is a
really seductive idea
that you should not fall into
if
the power of positive thinking means be
confident and hopeful
that's good yeah you should do that
right hope is a theological virtue and
confidence is an important thing and you
know it's attractive and we ought to do
it
if
we mean manifestation and the laws of
attraction and this new age gnostic
heresy what we're saying is that
we can make demands of god
and they will be fulfilled we can bring
god
force him into accord with our own will
that is
wicked i mean that's a really evil idea
you should not
uh do that and and that won't work by
the way i mean and
if it does seem to work for a time or
two uh that should have you even more
worried no have confidence have hope but
recognize it reigns on the just and the
unjust alike and
don't don't pervert your vision of the
world anymore one last question from
charlie hey michael question regarding
american culture i was wondering if you
think that america has a singular
culture a multicultural or no culture i
came across this question from school
and wanted to know what you thought
found myself stuck when i heard but i
knew you could answer because you're the
man thanks very much by the way huge fan
of the show blood speech just love it
very important on current issues from
wickety way have a great day thank you
anyway
america has neither a culture nor a
multicultural nor any of these other
cultures america has an anti-culture
it's an anti-culture right now
that is attacking the traditional
american culture so it's a culture of
debunking it's a it's a culture of
deconstruction it's a it's a culture of
tearing down everything that has made up
the culture it is an anti-culture and uh
and many other
thinkers and writers have talked about
this jacques borison talks about this
very well in dawn to decadence wonderful
history book of modernity
but you're saying you don't need a
history book to tell you this you're
seeing it happen all around you it's an
anti-culture
tearing down everything that's why we
need to i think eschew the the culture
of
debunking and deconstruction and
criticism ruthless criticism and
critical theory and we need to have
constructive thinking
in a culture that doesn't just debunk
but edifies i'm michael nolsas the
michael knowles show see monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moons turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me andrew clavin